Hallo.
Hallo, guten Tag. Ich stelle mich kurz vor.
Ich bin Dr. Kurt, Diensthabendarzt auf der Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen,
wenn Sie damit einverstanden sind.
Ja, genannte Dr. Kurt, ja, natürlich.
Mein Name ist auch ähnlich.
Ich bräuchte einfach Informationen über Sie, bevor wir anfangen.
Okay.
Ja, gerne, natürlich.
Okay, gut. Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Mein Name ist Michael.
Michael.
Reis.
Reis, Michael Reis.
Reis, genau.
Okay, also Michael.
Am Ende E, B, E, mit und A, wie so?
Michael, also Martha Ida Caesar Heinrich.
Ja.
Anton Emil Ludwig.
Emil.
Und Nachnamen, können Sie bitte Ihr Nachname bestellen?
Mein Nachname ist Reis.
Richard Emil Ida Siegfried Siegfried.
Also am Ende Z.
S. Siegfried Siegfried, also S. Reis.
Okay, am Ende Dapoulas. Okay, vielen Dank.
Wie heißen Sie Herr Reis?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
54 Jahre alt.
Bitte, dass Ihr Geburtstatum aufgeben.
Mein Geburtstatum ist 18. April 1968.
18. April 1968.
Ja.
Okay, wie heißen Sie?
Ich habe ein bisschen zu viel.
Ich habe im Moment 95 kg.
95 kg, okay.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Reis?
Ich glaube, als ich mich zuletzt gemessen habe, waren es 1 Meter 76.
6,76.
Vielen Dank für alle Informationen, Herr Reis.
Ja, was ist passiert?
Also, welcher Beschwerden führen Sie heute?
Herr Doktor Put, also seit 2 Tagen bekomme ich irgendwie schlechte Luft.
Wenn ich versuche, einzuatmen, dann klappt es nicht so.
Ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Seit 2 Tagen haben Sie schlechte Luft.
Ja.
Ja, wissen Sie, welchen Problem haben, wie zum Beispiel Erkältung oder so ähnlich?
Nein, Erkältung habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht gehabt.
Ich habe im Winter immer wieder Erkältungen, aber die letzte, die liegt jetzt seit 3 Monaten zurück.
Aber seit 2 Tagen merke ich, wenn ich versuche, etwas tiefer Luft zu holen, dann geht das nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Schmerzen beim Einatmen?
Was mir auffällt, ist, dass ich so an den linken Rippen...
Da tut es mir weh und das Strahl so ein bisschen nach vorne aus.
Und das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn ich suche, einzuatmen, dann sticht es auch dort, dann ist ein komisches Gefühl.
Also, stehende Gefühle.
Das ist ein Schmerzen, oder?
Nein, das ist schon ein richtiger Schmerz.
Schmerzen, okay.
Genau, ich kann dabei nicht einatmen.
Besonders am linken Seite, oder?
Am linken Seite, genau.
Okay, linken Seite.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt, Herr Reis?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Husten?
Fieber und Husten habe ich auch nicht.
Nicht? Okay.
Ja, und haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Nein, zu schlafen, das finde ich ganz gut.
Nein, aber wenn ich mich hinlege, dann ist es auch schwierig, etwas zu atmen.
Achso, okay.
Beim Hinleben...
Ich kann mich zum Beispiel nicht auf die linke Seite drehen.
Dann habe ich so ein Druckgefühl auf den Rippen.
Und dann kann ich auch nicht richtig einatmen.
Ich muss auf der rechten Seite schlafen.
Achso, okay.
Bei der linken Seite haben Sie Druckgefühl.
Das wird noch schlimmer.
Okay, das ist bestätigt.
Brauchen Sie zum Schlafen Kissen?
Nein, also ich schlafe eigentlich mit einem Kissen, und das reicht mir eigentlich.
Okay, Sie haben kein Husten, Sie haben kein Fieber.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ja gut, ich habe immer wieder auch mal so ein bisschen Rückenschmerzen.
Das ist aber fast schon chronisch bei mir.
Rückenschmerzen seit wann?
Auch das habe ich seit Jahren immer wieder.
Seit Jahren.
Okay, okay.
Gut, und ja, haben Sie, leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß oder?
Was meinen Sie mit Nachtschweiß?
Also ja, schwitzen Sie beim Schlafen.
Achso, nein, nein, nein, das nicht.
Kein Problem.
Aber ich habe halt immer wieder mal Magenschmerzen,
Gastritis und Sod brennen, und da muss ich immer wieder mal Tabletten nehmen.
Okay, Magenschmerzen und Sod brennen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Auch das ist auch schon seit Jahren immer wieder.
Auch seit Jahren.
Ja, ich habe da öfters auch schon eine Magenspiegelung gehabt.
Achso.
Und da hieß es immer, das ist ein Gastritis.
Ganz am Anfang hatte ich auch so Bakterien im Magen.
Da habe ich Antibiotika bekommen.
Aber trotzdem habe ich immer wieder so Magenschmerzen.
Okay, okay.
Aber aktuell ist es gesund oder?
Im Moment geht es mit dem Magen.
Das ist jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Da nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Das hilft mir ganz gut.
Aber es ist eher die Luft.
Also ich kriege dann immer auch so eine Art.
Aber ich habe richtig verstanden,
dass ich die Beschwerden Antibiotika einnehme.
Ich nehme für den Magen Medikamente ein.
Okay, Sie haben das eingenommen, das wurde behandelt.
Ja, vor vielen Jahren habe ich immer ein Antibiotika eingenommen.
Da hieß es nach einer Magenspiegelung,
dass ich Bakterien habe.
Aber das war vor zehn Jahren.
Okay, okay, gut.
Herr Reis und also jetzt möchte ich über Ihren allgemeinsten Stand
einige Fragen stellen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlasten, Stuhlgang?
Nein, das ist in Ordnung.
Da habe ich bisher glücklicherweise keine Probleme.
Okay, und da sind Sie schwindelig oder haben Sie überwältigt?
Nein, kein Problem.
Okay, ja.
Und möchtest du noch andere Beschwerden hinzufügen?
Das reicht, Roteinachs, mehr will ich nicht haben.
Ja, das ist, ja, ich glaube so.
Okay, gut.
Und jetzt vor Erkrankungen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Also ich habe einen hohen Blutdruck.
Blutdruck, blutdruck.
Und dann nehme ich zwei Medikamente ein.
Okay.
Seit wann erleiden Sie?
Der Blutdruck, ach so, ja, so seit circa seit fünf Jahren
nehme ich da Medikamente.
Seit fünf Jahren wählen Medikamente nehmen Sie ein, wissen Sie?
Oh, da muss ich nochmal nachschauen.
Als ich glaube, das eine nennt sich Bisoprolol.
Bisoprol, 5 Milligramm.
Bisoprolol, B-I-Z-O.
Bisoprolol, 5 Milligramm.
Okay, wie oft?
Einmal am Morgen.
Genau.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Kandesartan, 16 Milligramm.
Kandesartan.
Ja.
Wie viel Milligramm?
16 Milligramm.
6 Milligramm.
Okay.
Wie oft?
Das nehme ich einmal am Abend.
Einmal am Abend.
Okay.
Der Blutdruck stellt gut ein, oder?
Haben Sie irgendwelche Probleme?
Also der Hausarzt meint, das ist gut eingestellt.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und noch andere Vorerkrankungen.
Also, ja, mein Hausarzt macht das.
Nein, glücklicherweise habe ich jetzt bisher keinen Herzinfarkt gehabt.
In den Laboruntersuchungen, die mein Hausarzt macht,
waren die Zuckerwerte bisher auch immer in Ordnung.
Aber der Hausarzt sagt, der mein Cholesterin ist zu hoch
und der will, dass ich Medikamente nehme, aber ich will das nicht.
Achso, okay.
Wann wurde erhört, der Cholesterin festgestellt?
Also wissen Sie?
Ach gut, das ist uns auch seit vielen Jahren.
Ich glaube auch schon seit sechs, sieben Jahren.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Oder nur?
Nein, ich habe ja gerade gesagt,
mein Hausarzt will mir Medikamente geben.
Nein, mein Hausarzt will mir Medikamente gegen Cholesterin geben.
Aber ich will keine Medikamente.
Okay, Sie benutzen nicht die Medikamente.
Ich benutze gegen Cholesterin die Medikamente nicht.
Okay, wer hat Medikamente?
Gegen Cholesterin.
Er will mir gegen Cholesterin Medikamente geben,
aber die nehme ich nicht ein.
Sie möchte nicht Medikamente einnehmen.
Genau, gegen Cholesterin nehme ich keine Medikamente.
Okay, also das heißt, seit sechs Jahren stellt die Erhörte-Cholesterin nicht ein, oder?
Also Sie benutzen nicht Medikamente?
Nein, genau. Es ist nicht eingestellt.
Ach so, okay. Warum möchten Sie die Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe gehört von meinen Nachbarn und Freunden,
dass das Nebenwirkungen machen kann
und dass diese Medikamente nicht so gut sind.
Da habe ich Angst, deswegen will ich das nicht.
Also ich habe gehört, dass die Erhörte-Buletfetwerte gegen
eine andere Erkrankung so schlägt.
Also um das zu sagen, dass sie so zolt sind.
Ja, Doktor, wenn Sie das so ansprechen,
gegen welche Erkrankungen ist es nicht so gut?
Oder was ist das Risiko?
Ja, das ist Risiko für die Zumba-Espiel, ja,
auch für die Myokartinfarkt.
Also Sie sind 54 Jahre alt,
dass verursacht, also Arteriskorps, also ich meine...
Arteriskolose, was ist das?
Ja, das ist Verkalkung.
Ah, okay.
Ja, das ist sehr gefährlich.
Und auch, dass verursacht Diabetes oder so ähnliche Symptome...
Kolesterin macht Diabetes?
Also nicht macht, aber das ist,
also komplexe Situation, verstehen Sie?
Und deshalb, Kolesterin-Werte,
Bulutochdruck und Bulutzuka-Werte, das ist sehr wichtig.
Also das sollte zusammenstellen.
Und deshalb sollten Sie auch darauf atmen.
Deshalb, nein.
Aber ich denke, ich bin auch zu jung, ja.
Also ich bin noch 54, ich möchte keinen nicht so viel,
weil die kann man geeinnehmen.
Ich würde gerne noch ein bisschen warten.
Ja, ja, ich verstehe Sie ganz genau Herr Reis.
Also Sie machen Angst gegen irgendwelche Nebenwirkungen, okay.
Ich habe Angst wegen den Nebenwirkungen.
Ja, ja, ich verstehe, aber ich habe Angst auch für Ihre Gesundheit.
Also noch andere Probleme.
Deshalb müssen wir nach dem Anamnese gesprochen,
noch ausführlich darüber sprechen, okay?
Das können wir gerne machen, ja.
Das ist Dr. Zanacci.
Siegfried Anton, Nordpol Anton, Tina Christoph Ida.
Zanacci.
Okay, okay.
Wo liegt Ihr Hausarzt?
Also wo ist die Stadt?
Wie bitte?
Wo genau?
Wo ist die Praxis?
Also ist es in Mannheim?
Mannheim.
Okay, okay.
Gut, ich spreche mit Ihrem Hausarzt und dann können wir auch über diese
Thema noch mal sprechen, okay?
Sie können gerne mit meinem Hausarzt reden,
ich bleibe dabei.
Das ist wichtig, also okay, Herr Reis.
Und noch andere Vorerkrankungen, also das ist alles
Polesterinwerte und Bluthoffdruck.
Ansonsten ist sobald bisher alles in Ordnung.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, also,
ich meine Blinddarm oder Galaxie?
Ja, als Kind bin ich mal operiert worden, aber ansonsten...
Welche Operation hatten Sie?
Nicht erinnern.
Ja, der Blinddarm ist operiert worden.
Blinddarm operiert, okay.
Wie alt waren Sie?
Erinnern wahrscheinlich 12 Jahre alt oder so.
14 Jahre, okay.
Sind Sie diese Operation,
die Plikationslos, Verlaufnode?
Ich kann mich jetzt nicht erinnern,
ich kann mich jetzt nicht erinnern,
dass ich das noch nicht habe.
Okay, gut.
Noch andere Operation?
Nein, ich muss mich nicht.
Ja, jetzt Allergie, also Herr Reis?
Haben Sie ergehtwähl'allergie?
Ich meine, wie zum Beispiel
Kontrastmittlerallergie
oder Grazer, Polen,
Haustopmilbun?
Ja, ich bin gefühlt.
Ich bin gefühlt.
Ja, wirklich.
Ja, wie waren Sie?
Ich war gefühlt.
Wenn Sie mich so fragen, ich habe gegen einige Polen, die die Erle, Birke und Haselnuss.
Erle, Haselnuss und noch andere? Birke.
Birke, Polenalergien. Okay. Wie euch setzt sich die Allergien? Also wissen Sie?
Ja, da lasse mir die Nase, meine Augen brennen.
Nase, Augen brennen.
Medikamente und manchmal sogar auch in Sprechen nehmen.
Manchmal bekomme ich auch Schwerluft.
Und Luftnot.
Manchmal, ja.
Okay, Nase und Augen brennen und Luftnot.
Okay, welchen Medikament nehmen Sie dagegen?
Also, was mir gut hilft, ist dieses Zetirizin.
Zetirizin, okay.
Welche Dosierung wissen Sie?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht. Das ist eine Tablette, die hole ich aus dem Start.
Okay. Aber nur bei Bedarf.
Ja, ja.
Okay, gut und noch andere? Alergien?
Nein.
Nein, also Missuka, Missumba, Spil.
Ach so, nein, nein.
Ja, gut, ja. Können Sie mir sagen, ob Sie rauchen, Herr Reis?
Ich rauche nein.
Nie? Nein.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Das gehört mich.
Also, dass Sie haben sehr gut gemacht.
Also, okay. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Manchmal, ja.
Manchmal. Was trinken Sie manchmal? Was meinen Sie?
Ich mag gerne Rotwein.
Rotwein, okay.
Ich habe manchmal auch ein Bier.
Bier, also, was meinst du?
Bei Noah Party oder am Wochenende oder Einglas oder Einflaschen?
Genau, also nicht immer heißt, wenn man mal zum Essen geht
oder bei einer Feierlichkeit.
Okay, Noah, zu bestimmten Anlässen.
Ja, genau.
Okay. Und ja, diese Frage ist, Routine Frage, Herr Reis.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen oder haben Sie davon?
Nein, also meine schlimmste Droge sind Chips und Schokokeks.
Ach so, okay.
Das ist für alle.
Andere.
Drogen habe ich jetzt nicht.
Okay, okay.
Das ist für mich, das geht auch für mich.
Ja, Sie machen keine Droge.
Und was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Reis?
Ich arbeite im Büro.
Büro.
Ja, ich bin Projektmanager.
Manager.
Projektmanager.
Okay.
Also Sie sitzen, also Sie haben eine sitzende Berufstätigkeit,
oder?
Ja, ich beweisen Sie im Büro, ja.
Okay, okay.
Leiden Sie unter Stress oder wie ist das?
Was haben wir genug gerade?
Also bei der Arbeit ist schon immer viel zu tun.
Okay, Sie sind damit so viel im Haus, kein Problem.
Das heißt, zufrieden wir.
Natürlich, ich liebe meine Arbeit.
Okay, sehr gut.
Okay, gut.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Okay, und haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben zwei Kinder, ja.
Zwei Kinder, okay, sehr gut.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder meinen Sie?
Ja, ja, glückweise.
Die haben bisher keine Erkrankungen, die das ganz gut haben.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ja, also jetzt möchte ich, also die Familien am Nese ein gefragt stellen.
Also Leben, ihr erhält noch?
Meine Eltern leben noch, ja.
Sehr gut, sind Sie gesund, Vater, Mutter oder Schüttgeschwister?
Also denen geht es gut.
Ja, gut, ist ja immer so, natürlich haben Sie so Ihre kleinen Beweichen.
Bewege, ihr Vater oder?
Ja, also Sie haben so Ihre kleinen Beweichen,
also das heißt da, Sie haben Ihre Erkrankungen, aber Ihnen geht es gut.
Also welche Erkrankungen können Sie noch mal sagen, ich habe nicht gut gehört?
Mit Beweichen meint man, dass die kleine Erkrankungen haben, also Alterserscheinungen.
Was meine ich, wie hast du Probleme oder Lungenprobleme?
Wenn Sie mich aussprechen lassen, Herr Doktor, dann kann ich das auch sagen.
Sie unterbrechen mich die ganze Zeit, Doktor.
Sie müssen mir zeigen, dass ich sprechen kann.
Also mein Vater hat einen hohen Blutdruck, nimmt auch Medikamente.
Okay.
Und er hat schon langsam auch so ein bisschen Knieprobleme.
Das heißt, er zeigt oder so, dann hat er Schmerzen.
Und die Augen sehen wohl auch nicht mehr so gut.
Er meint, dass er bald operiert werden muss.
Operiert werden muss, okay.
Ja, und meine Mutter leidet schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren über chronische Darmprobleme.
Das heißt, sie muss da manchmal Medikamente nehmen.
Sie hat oft auch Stopfungen und Verdauungsprobleme.
Okay, das ist verständlich.
Okay, gut.
Also Knieprobleme haben Sie gesagt, also, was meine ich, das ist ein Entzündung?
Wahrscheinlich Arthrose.
Okay, okay.
Und Blutdruck, um seit wann hat Ihr Vater?
Das weiß ich jetzt, das ist auch schon, glaube ich, seit 30 Jahren.
Okay, und Augenprobleme?
Das ist ein, also Grauesteuer oder Grünesteuer oder wegen der Arthrose?
Da bin ich jetzt überfragt.
Okay, okay.
Meint, dass er bald operiert werden muss.
Aber ich glaube, das war der Grauesteuer, was er hat.
Grauesteuer, okay.
Aber noch nicht operiert worden, also eine Planung.
Nee, das ist noch geplant.
Es steht noch an.
Okay, okay.
Gute Besserung, also Info raus.
Danke.
Und, okay, und chronische Darmprobleme hat die Mutter, also was meinen Sie,
das ist ein Krebs oder ein Gutartgetüme oder Entzündung?
Nein, wo hat sie jetzt nicht, das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Sie hat einfach nur Darmprobleme, sie hat Verstopfungen,
Blähungen und nicht mehr Nehentriff.
Ja, gut, manchmal ist es schon schlimm für Sie, also Sie hat da manchmal Schmerzen.
Okay, okay.
Das geht so nicht so gut.
Ja, okay, noch möchte ich eine Frage stellen.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch eine Schwester, ja.
Okay, ist sie gesund?
Ich muss mal überlegen, soweit ich weiß, hat sie jetzt keine Beschwerden?
Nein.
Keine Beschwerden.
Mhm.
Gut, ja, also Herr Reis, ich denke, ich habe erst alle für mich
die wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Sie haben aber viele Fragen heute gestellt.
Aber für sie gesund, um eine richtige Diagnose stellen zu können,
ist das sehr wichtig.
Ja, und wissen Sie schon, warum ich jetzt diese Luftnot habe?
Ja, das ist, ja, bisher haben Sie so viele Informationen gegeben.
Das ist richtig, Herr Reis, aber das ist nicht genug.
Immer noch nicht genug?
Ja, leider, das ist nur eine Anamnese gesprungen.
Natürlich habe ich eine Verdastdiagnose, aber jetzt kann ich nicht so viel sagen, okay?
Das ist nicht bestimmte Symptome, also eine Diagnose entscheidend zu treffen.
Aber ja, ich möchte Sie zuerst die Körperunterzüge, okay?
Okay.
Danach mache ich eine Leberuntersuch.
Ein Kollege wird bei Ihnen mit der Luft abnehmen, okay?
Ja, das ist okay, das finde ich gut.
Ja, gut.
Dann, ja, es sollte ein Rundgenaufnahme gegebenenfalls Komfortatomographie,
vielleicht MRT.
Ach Gott, das machen Sie alles heute Abend, oder?
Es kommt darauf an, also Herr Reis.
Ich möchte Sie zuerst die Körperunterzüge, ja, dann sprechen wir noch darüber, okay?
Aber natürlich, ich spreche mit meinem Oberst dann.
Aber ich muss nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben, oder?
Weil ich will nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ja, also, ich denke ja, aber es kann sein.
Ja, auch.
Ich möchte nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Nein.
Ja, ja, aber wenn es ist, wenn es ist,
ich möchte nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Korona ist überall, also.
Ja, deswegen.
Ich mache mir schon Sorgen, meine Frau.
Ja, ja, ja.
Sie waren hier in diesem Krankenhaus, sie musste an einem Leisten beruf operiert werden,
und dann hat sie im Krankenhaus Korona bekommen, also.
Ja, das ist möglich.
Aber wie ich gesagt habe, ist das Risiko, also die Städte, das Risiko überall,
also auch draußen, auch draußen,
das Risiko, das Risiko, das Risiko, das Risiko, das Risiko, das Risiko,
das Risiko überall, also auch draußen, auch Hause, auch kann, kann,
okay.
Ja, das ist mir schon klar, aber wenn ich es nicht sagen muss,
möchte ich nicht gerne im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ja, ja, okay.
Ich werde Ihnen sehr dankbar, wenn Sie feststellen können,
was ich habe, und ich würde dann schon gerne nach Hause gehen wollen.
Okay, gut, also dann können wir noch mal spielen, okay?
Okay.
Jetzt machen wir einige Unterzugs.
Aber ja, wenn Sie nicht möchten, natürlich, also haben Sie recht,
also mit einem Papier diese Untersuchung ablehnen, also das ist kein Problem.
Okay, aber ich empfehle Ihnen, die Untersuchungen lehne ich nicht ab.
Ich sage nur, dass ich nicht gerne im Krankenhaus bleiben möchte,
wenn ich da meine.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe also, ich meine nach der Untersuchung,
so sollten wir, also machen wir, entscheiden wir einige,
über einige Idee treffen, okay, dann empfehlen wir Ihnen also,
ob Sie...
Sie meinen, wir machen jetzt erstmal die Untersuchungen
und dann sprechen wir noch mal.
Okay, ja, dann...
Das ist eine gute Idee, finde ich cool.
Dann, ob Sie, also dann, wir können einfach schauen,
ob Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben sollten oder müssen, okay?
Alles klar.
Das hört sich gut mit daran.
Okay, das hört sich gut mit daran.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Okay, gut, ich nehme Sie nicht mit.
Okay, dann, ja, ich gebe Ihnen die Zeit.
Ich habe so ein bisschen Angst wegen dem Herz.
Schauen Sie auch danach, auch noch mal?
Ja, ja, ja, das ist möglich.
Also, wir haben eine Ekokardiografie, also okay.
Alles ist gut, das machen Sie, alles wird gemacht, okay?
Machen Sie es, keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Okay, gut.
Gut, danke Herr Doktor.
Wo soll ich Platz nehmen?
Ja, also draußen, also geht ein Wartezimmer, okay?
Wenn Sie möchten, können Sie einfach die Kollegen...
Ein Wartezimmer, okay.
Wunderbar, gut, danke schön, dann nehme ich ein Wartezimmer.
Okay, danke schön.
Okay.
Gut.
Ein anstrengender Patient.
Ja, das ist immer möglich, kein Problem.
Ja, wir müssen also damit zurückkommen.
Sehr gut.
Okay, machen wir dann jetzt eine Übergabe an den Oberarzt?
Ja, aber ich würde einfach fragen, ich habe eigentlich nicht richtige, gute Diagnose,
das ist für mich nur, also nicht, also unsere Fall in München, deshalb...
Ja, okay.
Ich kann nicht direkt denken, also welcher Fall.
Wollen Sie jetzt noch ein paar Minuten Überlegung und Bedenkzeichen?
Nein, vielleicht, wir können uns zusammen eine Entscheidung treffen, oder?
Ja, deswegen, klar, also ich würde vorschlagen, ich bin jetzt der Oberarzt, Sie stellen mir jetzt erstmal Ihren Patienten vor, Herr Doktor Kurz.
Ja, okay.
Dann können wir uns gemeinsam überlegen, was die Arbeitsdiagnose ist oder wie?
Okay, gut, ja, wir können auch sagen, okay, wir können auch sagen.
Aber wenn Sie jetzt noch ein paar Minuten brauchen, um Ihre Analyse da zusammenzufassen,
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
dann können Sie sich auch gerne mit den anderen Kollegen unterhalten.
Also, ich kann direkt anfangen, kein Problem.
Aber wenn Sie möchten, können Sie einfach...
Ja, ich habe Zeit, deswegen bin ich da, dann machen Sie bitte jetzt mal Ihre Übergabe.
Was für einen Patienten haben Sie heute angenommen?
Bitte schön.
Okay, also, ja, guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen heute gerne den 54-jährigen Patient, Herr Reis vorstellen.
Er ist am 10. April 1968 geboren.
Er ist 95 Kilogramm schwer und 1 Meter 76 groß.
Ja, Herr Reis stellte sich heute regelseitig zwei Tage den bestehenden inspiratorischen Düsseln bei uns vor.
Der inspiratorische Düsseln?
Ist inspiratorische.
Inspiratorische, inspiratorische.
Oder ja, vielleicht stellte sich heute wegen einer Düsseln,
der Patient klagt über Besonders beim Einatmen dieser Beschwerden.
Wo sind die Schmerzen beim Einatmen?
Ja, die Schmerzen
seien besonders am linken Rippenbogen aufgetreten und die Schmerzen
hätten in vorne Seite gestrahlt.
Also, strahlen ventral aus oder?
Ja, ja, ich sehe das.
Sie haben mit ventralen Ausstrahlung.
Ja.
Ja, und der Patient berichtete, dass er beim Hinlegen
sich noch schlecht fühlen sollte.
Deshalb sollte er auf die rechte Seite schlafen.
Er hat bei der linken Seite Druckgefühl.
Und seit fünf Jahren habe der Patient chronische Lumbalgie.
Lumbalgie?
Rücken Schmerzen hat der Patient gesagt.
Ja, okay.
In welcher Höhe haben Sie jetzt nicht gefragt?
Der Patient hat gesagt, Rücken Schmerzen.
Ja, aber in welcher Höhe ist es die Halsverbeseule?
Ja, ja, richtig.
Das haben Sie nicht nachgefragt?
Ja, also okay, beide Köpfe.
Das ist ein Problem.
Ja, richtig, sollte ich fragen.
Ja, der Patient habe seit vielen Jahren Rücken Schmerzen.
Ja, die vegetative Amnesie sei unauffällig.
An vollkrankungen seien seit fünf Jahren arterielle Hypertonie.
Seit circa sechs, sieben Jahren ist eine Hypercholosteronemie bekannt.
Aber die Hypercholosteronemie wurde nicht behandelt.
Seien nicht behandelt worden, weil der Patient nicht Medikamente einnehmen möchte.
Mit zwölf Jahren habe sich eine Appendectomy unterzogen.
Die Medikamente an Amnesien ergab die regelmäßige Bisoprolol.
Das sind 5 mg morgens und kann das Ertagen abends 6-10 mg abends.
Ja, okay.
Der Patient hat eine Polnallergie mit brennenden Augen und Nasen.
Wie nennt sich das mit brennenden Augen oder Nasen?
Ja, das ist ein Rhinitis.
Rhinitis?
Ja, das ist ein Rhinokonjuktivitis.
Rhinokonjuktivitis, okay.
Ja, Rhinokonjuktivitis und Nüsse.
Ja, deswegen habe ich auch eine Medikamente mit Stetrizien tablett.
Okay, das ist eine Antialergie.
Ja, richtig.
Also, Entschuldigung.
Die Kontinuen, die ich hier habe, wurden verneinzt.
Das hat herrschen geheiratet, habet 2 Kinder, sie ist nicht gesund
und arbeitet im Büro als Projektmanager.
Okay.
Okay, gut.
Ja, Vater leide an...
Sein Vater?
Entschuldigung, ja sein Vater.
Sein Vater leide an einer arteriellen Hypertonie.
Er habe am Knie, also Bonatrose, oder ja, Bonatrose.
Bonatrose, oder?
Und Katarakt.
Okay.
Ja, wird eine Operation geplant.
Wird vorgenommen oder ist eine Operation geplant?
Ja, deswegen ist eine Operation geplant.
Ja, genau.
Ist geplant, ja richtig.
Okay, und seine Mutter habe seit vielen Jahren, ja, dann, also irgendwie eine Damekrankung,
habe sie Obstipation und sie nehmen dagegen Medikamente ein.
Ein Schwester, sie sind gesund, ja, sie haben keine Krankung.
Ja, also aufgrund der bisherigen Anamnesenangaben,
Geh von, ja, Pücher Pünomonie.
Eine was? Eine?
Atypücher Pünomonie.
Atypücher Pünomonie?
Ja, Astipharanzaldiagnosen, common, also, ja,
Herzinsufficiency oder vielleicht Skoliose.
Haben sie gefragt, ja, okay, also das sind jetzt die Defizitiatriagnosen,
aber haben sie den Patienten gefragt, ob er eine instabile AP hat,
oder indem er eine instabile AP, also Angina Pectoris,
ja, eigentlich,
Sie haben nicht gefragt, okay, haben Sie gefragt,
wenn Sie ein Herzinsuffizienz denken, wonach müssen Sie noch fragen?
Ja, deshalb habe ich...
Ob Udeme, ob Udeme in den Beinen hat, das haben Sie nicht gefragt?
Ja, ja, Udeme vielleicht ja, aber das wäre Ihnen sicherlich
bei der körperlichen Untersuchung dann aufgefallen.
Ja, ja, richtig, dass wir können beide Untersuchungen beurteilen,
ob der Patient hat oder nicht.
Ja, das ist aber ja einfach die finanzielle Diagnose.
Okay, woran denken Sie noch?
Also, was meinst du, also die beide...
Weitere, weitere oder andere Diagnose,
was kann es noch sein?
Vielleicht können die anderen Kollegen und Kolleginnen auch noch helfen?
Also es kann auch vielleicht...
Multibismeulom, okay.
Es kann auch vielleicht auch ein Unfall sein,
also vielleicht der Patient hat linke Seite gegen irgendetwas gestoßen und deshalb...
Aber Sie haben doch den Patienten gefragt, der hat doch keinen Unfall gehabt?
Ja, kein...
Also, der Patient ist 54 Jahre alt.
Am linken Seite hat der Patient Schmerzen...
Auf der linken Seite?
Auf der linken Seite Schmerzen und einatmen, das kann ein...
Also zweisseitige Misstruktur sein.
Eine was kann es sein?
Eine Mehlzropptur.
Ja, zweisseitige Misstruktur, also das ist vielleicht nicht in der Stiline.
Aber er hat ja keinen Trauma, haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, richtig, kein Trauma, aber wie ich gesagt habe...
Aber er ist doch im Moment kreislaufstabier, normalerweise.
Ja, aber wie ich gesagt habe, das kann auch eine zweisseitige Misstruktur sein.
Am Anfang bleibt der so nicht intakt.
Und der Patient hat nicht bemerkt, vielleicht hat er irgendwas gestoßen, aber das hat...
Aber das muss ja schon ein heftiger Stoß sein, ne?
Eine Mehlstruktur geht ja nicht einfach so.
Ja, der Patient...
Aber gut, lassen wir mal stehen.
Ja, das Alter und...
Wir können ja mit einer Sonneografie kontrollieren und schauen.
Ja, ja, ja, richtig.
Also das ist so weniger infrage.
Okay, was kann es noch sein?
Das ist ganz einfach. Vorhin kamen ein paar Vorschläge von den Kollegen.
Da war das, glaube ich, so gerade dabei.
Ja, Pynomotorax auch, also wegen dem...
Ja, auch eine Möglichkeit.
Aber ja, also wenn es Pynomotorax eine Möglichkeit ist,
auch Misstruktur, einem Pynomotorax, von Tampinen...
Ja, ich sage ja, das ist eine von seltenen Möglichkeiten,
aber da kann es so denken.
Natürlich, kann schon mal sein, ja.
COPD, also der Patient raucht nicht und COPD ist nicht.
Genau. Aber klar, muss man sagen.
Es kann sein, natürlich.
Ja, unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, unwahrscheinlich, wie Misstruktur, aber es kann auch sein.
Ja.
Was weiteres vorgehen, schlage ich vorhin,
das vor, ja, nach der Vitalparameter-Überpürofung
und der Körper-Untersuch, plan ich eine Labo-Untersuch,
also mit Bestenmück von...
Ja, kleines Blutbild, auch Enzymusparameter, Nieren und Leberwerte,
auch Schittdrösenwerte, so wie mit und P3, T4,
auch absoluten Gelbungsparameter.
Ja, danach sollten eine Röntgenaufnahme...
Machen Sie auch Herzentzüme mit?
Wie bitte? Herzentzüme.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Ja, das sollte ein Herzentzüme...
Welche sind das?
Herzentzüme, wie zum Beispiel Troponin,
also Troponin T, Troponin U, TKMB, TKMB, ja.
Jawoll.
Das sollte überprüft werden.
Was würden Sie noch mitmachen,
wenn Sie schon Blut abnehmen, welche Laboparameter in Bezug auf die Lunge
oder eine Lungenembolie?
Ja, die Lungenembolie, also Auslöschen,
wäre es wichtig, die Edime, also...
Die Edime, richtig, würde ich mitmachen.
Ja, richtig, die Edime zu beprüfen, ja, natürlich.
Ja, und Röntgenaufnahme, LKG, Zoltem...
Ja, Röntgen und LKG sind wichtig, genau.
Ja, natürlich.
Und ja, der Patient kollagt über Luftnoten
und auch Blutgasanalyse.
Ja, gut, ja, so eine kleine Blutgasanalyse wäre es sehr sinnvoll, genau.
Ja, ja, das ist...
Und damit können Sie eigentlich relativ vieles ausschließen,
beispielsweise unterstützen
und dann würden wir das weitere vorgehen
oder das weitere Prozedere noch mal besprechen.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Genau, aber eine Diagnose, die der Patient eigentlich haben könnte,
haben Sie bisher aber noch nicht gesagt.
Ganz einfach.
Ganz einfach, ja, ich glaube daran, aber...
Ja, ja...
Schau mal in dem Chat, ob es dabei ist.
Es gibt dabei oder?
Ja, es ist dabei.
Dorsalgi.
Was passt so dorsalgi?
Da ist aber noch genauer.
Schauen Sie mal in dem Chat verlauf, da ist es dabei.
Rippuntumor, oder Insulina.
Nicht Rippuntumor.
Intekostale neuralgie.
Intekostale neuralgie, genau.
Was ist das?
Ja, also...
Wer hat es geschrieben?
Wer soll es bestellen?
Pirdews.
Eine Frau Dr. Pirdews?
Frau Dr.
Was ist eine Intekostale neuralgie?
Wo ist sie?
Ich höre nichts.
Wollen Sie mich jetzt?
Jetzt ist es besser.
Also, was ist eine Intekostale neuralgie, Frau Dr.
Eine schmarske Füll.
Eine Schmarske, die sich in Ihrem Intekostalbereich
besonders beim Drücken verschlechtert ist.
Also Sie wollen sagen, das ist eine Reizung der Rippennerven.
Ja.
Genau, ganz einfach.
Also, Herr Dr. Kurz, das ist eine Reizung der Rippennerven.
Woher kommen die Rippennerven aus der Wirbelsäule?
Die kommen aus der Wirbelsäule, gehen entlang der Rippen
und ziehen nach vorne.
Okay, okay.
Das heißt, meistens hat man, wenn man Rückenschmerzen hat,
also eine Dorsalgie oder Muskelverspannungen,
dann können diese Rippennerven gereizt werden
und diese Schmerzen strahlen dann von Rückend bis nach vorne
in den Brust aus.
Bei jeder Torachsbewegung, wenn Sie ein- und ausatmen
und bei jeder Bewegung des Torachs, der Patient hat ja gesagt,
wenn er sich auf die linke Seite hinlegt,
dann schmerzt das, dann tut es ihm weh.
Das heißt, bei jeder Reizung der Rippennerven
können diese Schmerzen stechend sein
und das ist meistens einfach eine ganz einfache Sache.
Verspannung der Rückendmuskulatur, eine leichte Erkältung
oder sie haben etwas Schweres gehoben, lange Sitzende Tätigkeit,
arbeitet da im Büro, hat auch ein bisschen Stress.
Also ich denke, dass er einfach eine interkustale Neurogy hat.
Das blockiert beim Einatmen.
Wenn man tief einatmen möchte, dann blockiert das
und dann kann er nicht richtig durchatmen.
Das macht manchmal auch Panik, Unruhe, Atemnot.
Und so steigern sich die Menschen.
Ja, richtig. Das kann sein, ja. Das ist vernünftig.
Also es gibt ein Sprichwort, das heißt, was wenig ist,
ist wenig und was viel ist, ist viel.
Das heißt, eine Milzruptur oder andere Sachen können natürlich sein,
aber das ist eher seltener oder ist viel.
Unwahrscheinlich. Natürlich muss man dran denken, das ist richtig.
Also meine Arbeitsdiagnose wäre als erstes mal eine interkustale Neurogy.
Der zweite Diagnose, was ich ausschließen würde,
wäre ein Herzinfarkt oder ein akutes Coronasyndrom.
Denn er ist 54 Jahre alt, er hat ein Hypertonus,
er hat eine Hypocholesterinemie,
er hat eine positive Familienanamnese.
Der Vater ist auch ein Hypertonus erkrankt.
Daher würde ich natürlich auch ein Herzinfarkt als erstes ausschließen
mit einer Metragie.
Der Röntgen-Torax ist auch gut.
Damit kann ich sehen, ob da ein Pneumotorax ist,
ob da eine Pneumonie da ist.
Natürlich kann auch eine Pneumonie
oder eine atypische Pneumonie sich auch so äußern, ganz klar.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Da müsste man aber im Labor ein hohes CRP erwarten.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Gut, jetzt habe ich es schon mal ein bisschen geärgert, glaube ich,
oder, Doktor?
Ja, ja, nein, nein, das war sehr gut.
Vielleicht ein, zwei Punkte.
Sie sind Facharzt für was?
Also gerade nicht.
Nur einiges Zeit als Notarzt in der Türkei gearbeitet.
Aber jetzt nur ein paar...
Sie sind noch in der Ausbildung gewesen als Assistenzarzt.
Ja, ja, jetzt denke ich nur zwei Mal Rostassin gemacht.
Okay.
Also, vielleicht ein paar Punkte.
Sie sprechen das schon ganz gut.
Die deutsche Sprache, manchmal verwechseln sie männlich und weiblich.
Er und sie, sie sind manchmal zu hektisch, zu schnell.
Sie lassen den Patienten nicht ausreden.
Sie unterbrechen den Patienten.
Das ist nicht gut.
Sie müssen den Patienten aussprechen lassen.
Sie unterbrechen den Patienten.
Ja, also...
Dann sagen Sie mal, ja, ja, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Okay, okay, okay.
Und unterbrechen den Patienten.
Warum so?
So wie jetzt zum Beispiel Sie unterbrechen den Patienten.
Abwarten, zuhören und dann reden.
Okay.
Also, normalerweise gibt es nervöse oder sehr sprechende Patienten.
Und wir simulieren das.
Deshalb wollte ich so sagen, wir haben 20 Minuten.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ja, und deshalb, also, ich möchte so stehen wie möglich,
so viele Passionen vom Patienten.
Und ja, und ja.
Ja, trotzdem ist es natürlich nicht sehr höflich
und nicht so freundlich den Patienten gegenüber,
wenn man sie unterbricht.
Ja, ja, das ist richtig.
Ja, beide Familien am Nese habe ich bemält.
Anfang habe ich wegen der Internet nicht gehört.
Sie haben nur kleine Erkrankungen so ähnlich gesagt.
Ich habe gedacht, Sie...
Genau, das wollte ich sagen.
Was es bedeutet, das habe ich ganz bewusst auch gesagt.
Kleine Wehwähchen ist auch so ein Ausdruck in der Deutschen.
Kleine Wehwähchen, was ist das?
Wehwähchen.
Das heißt, wenn du Schmerzen hast, dann sagst du, es tut mir weh.
Okay.
Darf ich auswählen?
Also, man sagte, es tut mir weh, weh tun.
Das bedeutet Schmerzen haben.
Und mit kleinen Wehwähchen meint man, er hat kleine Erkrankungen
oder wenige, einige Erkrankungen.
Okay, okay.
Ich habe gedacht, dass Sie also irgendwelche Erkrankungen sagen
und wir haben keine Probleme, wir haben nichts gehört.
Ja, okay.
Und deshalb, also, vorbeikommen andere Situationen.
Ich möchte Sie zweimal unterbrechen.
Okay, aber kein Problem.
Genau.
Ich wollte Sie jetzt nicht ärgern, aber ich wollte Sie ein bisschen
als Arzt herausfordern.
Ja, das ist...
Sehr gut.
Aber Sie machen es sehr gut, ganz toll.
Dankeschön.
Was ist bei Ihnen die Prüfung?
Ascent, Ascent, Mars.
Das ist also in so zwei...